this terminal I should make my piece
with that but it's difficult all my
peers have hair and plans for the future
and I'm just like constricted by this
thing that's trying to kill me in my
brain
[Music]
what was your childhood like
I had a great childhood I spent most of
it playing outside with my sister
and our neighbors and
couldn't have asked for anything better
I was always quite a curious kid I liked
um stones and
um architecture
um I also did a lot of running as well
of cross country when I was younger and
when he finished school what kind of
what did you decide to do what was your
inspiration
um well I went and studied
um PPE politics philosophy economics at
University of Manchester but actually
the year that I
um finished
um
Secondary School sixth form in the
summer between starting University
and finishing school I I had an
internship in America and I was out
there for about six weeks all together
um
and then back to study at King's College
London
um in the September what would you say
was the day that kind of changed the
course of your life
the 7th of November 2018 so I was
applying to the the Royal Navy unit of
the university in London
and I got in and they said in order to
be like completely confirmed you need to
finish this medical and that involved an
eye test at boots
and
um the woman took a picture behind my
eye
and she said I can't pass you on this
medical because there seems to be
pressure building up behind your eye
um please go to this eye hospital they
didn't really tell me much that they ran
a lot of tests but they didn't say that
anything was wrong
um and then the next day
was probably the worst day of my life
mom and Grace came down
um from from up North so it was about
200 miles there to come
um and they didn't trust me when I said
I was okay so they came down and somehow
managed to get into my
um my flat I wasn't able to open the
door because I was throwing up and just
generally really tired so they got in
and my mum looked at me and decided she
was going to take me to the nearest
hospital somehow I managed to get a CT
scan at like three o'clock in the
morning
um which is quite a rare thing
um because normally you have to wait
hours and hours and you don't get them
in the middle of the night so they had
this CT scan and a bit later on she came
in and she said um
you've got
um brain tumors
well at that time there was only two
they later did an MRI and found out
there were eight so the first one was
here it was about the size of a golf
ball
um and she was like right we're gonna
have to have surgery and take it out
immediately because at that point it was
wearing my brain lining then
so on that day
um I was supposed to have the operation
at Salford hospital and ended up having
a tonic clonic seizure that morning
um and it was only because we were
getting up so early early for the
appointment that my sister noticed that
I wasn't I was just staring at the
ceiling I wasn't I wasn't like getting
ready to go for surgery or anything my
dad thought I was really scared just
wasn't like comprehending the situation
or something and then I started fitting
I don't remember any of this
at all this is all based on what I've
Been Told
so
there's somehow managed to get an
ambulance so far drive put me in the
ambulance and take me there I had to
take it to the nearest hospital so I
ended up being taken to Blackburn and
then being transferred from Blackburn to
um
sulfur so I could still have the
operation and because I wasn't conscious
they were a bit wary of giving me the
operation
because he needs yet that like it would
be worth doing it in the first place
um and even though I wouldn't
um I wouldn't respond or anything he did
the surgery anyway
and that's why I'm still here
what was your initial reaction when
you've heard about your photographs how
did it feel
um
I just thought this is wrong this can't
be me I'm just I'm 18.
this isn't right and then when we did
the stats we found out that it it kind
of wasn't right
what I had was more common in men and
older men as well
like above 60. I'm the wrong demographic
for this
my um I shouldn't I shouldn't really
have this you know I'd expect someone
to get a brain tumor
and not a terminal diagnosis at the age
of 18.
I just felt like a rug has been pulled
on from under me I had this whole life
plan about like what I was going to do
what I was gonna do it and how it was
going to happen and then
this one bit of news
and my life changed and planned it out
the window it's terminal I should make
my piece with that but
is difficult when all of that happened
how much did
the doctors how much did they give you
to live initially what did they tell you
um somewhere between between 12 and 18
months
and I asked if I would be able to go
back to University the doctor told me I
wouldn't
I am full stop
never mind graduating but he said you
can't go back to University
um
as in it wouldn't be physically possible
with what you've got now
um
so I decided I was going to go back to
University and prove him wrong
but yeah it's difficult coming to terms
with with something like that and I'm
not even sure I've I'm there at the
moment what about your family when they
found out what was your dances what what
was their reaction
well it's like the worst thing you can
possibly hear
when your sister or your daughter's got
terminal diagnosis it broke them
in many ways but I feel like we've
managed to forge together and we're
stronger as well definitely
so before you got diagnosed and before
you had that eye test even do you think
you had any hints or any symptoms that
what that you might have you having
something
um I did I had really bad head pain
which is one of the symptoms for
um brain tumors
um I had it
um one time that like
it was so bad I couldn't see
it kind of pressed on me what I know now
is the optic nerve and it made me go
blind I also had
um a seizure I think
um I remember lying on bed
um
at Uni and calling my mum and then
not really remembering what's happened
and then waking up on on the floor with
like bruises all the way down the side
of my head so I'd obviously been on the
floor and done some fitting or something
but I had no idea what was going on but
I'm actually quite lucky to have found
it when I did
if I didn't have that operation on the
seventh I wouldn't be here right now my
sister wouldn't have woken me up and I
would have died fitting
what is the recovery from brain surgery
like
it differs depending on the person I
suppose when I was first diagnosed I
decided I was going to be
um I would be campaigning against brain
tumors so I joined a young Ambassador
group for the brain tumor charity and I
met a lot of people there
that have similar things to me
um
but have had different reactions in a
way I'm quite lucky
um I've had friends that can't see any
more friends that have like can only use
the right leg or something and
me I've not really had any
long-term side effects from anything at
the moment
sure I'm unwell on certain days and I
feel sick but other than that I'm doing
all right so what is the state of your
tumor now
so they either scan a couple of weeks
ago and I thought it would be a good
scan because I've been having no no
symptoms no headaches or anything
um and then
it turned out that
um
so they've taken the tumor out most of
it and they couldn't get to the lining
bits because it was sucking it out in
like a suction and couldn't get to to
all of the bits because
there were the blood vessels that are um
actually
feeding the blood to my legs how much
time do you think you spend all in all
in the hospital by now
it depends on the treatment I'm having I
suppose maybe about
two hours a month
maybe a bit less
maybe three or four
hours it depends on what I'm having I
mean the scans are quick
the radiotherapy was relatively quick
um
chemo should be all right as well
I'm just hoping I don't lose my hair
this time
all my eyebrows or eyelashes because
that can really
knock you out of place a little bit when
you go into a room and everyone's just
staring at the Baldi
and you're like but this isn't fair all
my peers have hair and plans for the
future
and I'm just like constricted by this
thing that's trying to kill me in my
brain
and it's quite difficult to keep a
positive attitude but
there are a lot of people that think
that having a positive attitude could be
the cure for this
um like my dad especially well
yeah I try I try
do you think your view on life and death
do you think it changed since you've
been diagnosed
yeah definitely
I think before I used to like most
people think well Life Will Go On I'll
live till I'm 80.
put problems after tomorrow
um
but now obviously that's changed so
I'm looking for today as much as I can
it's difficult between treatment and
stuff and
I'm getting a lot of support from the
community not just my family
um and that's quite important to say
because we've kind of built up an online
social media
um help service I suppose for people
that have also got children or people
that they know that I've got
tumors but it's um it's been a tough
Journey it's coming up to four years
we've just passed four years actually
and that's quite an achievement so
you've said before that when the doctor
told you you're never going to be able
to go back to the university you wanted
to prove him wrong so did you prove him
wrong I did yes it was quite tough to
stay focused on the actual course
and still be having treatment I did
radiotherapy at the start
um of my degree and ended up finishing
it the same way
um so
it's like a full circle thing but um I
managed it yeah
I managed to get a 2-1 in PPE which I'm
quite proud of
and yeah it's quite a significant thing
the fact that I got it after all and I
sent him a picture of me and my
graduation gown as well my doctor so he
can put that on the wall and remind
people that there is still hope
that
terminal diagnosis doesn't mean stop
don't
carry on fighting don't think your life
is up completely
because there's always something that
you can
research or someone you can talk to
um
and
yeah yeah keep on
what would you say to someone else
watching it right now who have either
been diagnosed with the terminal disease
I have a loved one what advice would you
give them get yourself informed
learn as much as you can because in
these situations knowledge is power
and what the doctor may suggest
might not be the right thing for you
don't be afraid to question it
um you know yourself better than anyone
um
I'm getting contact if you need
information do you still plan do you
plan for the future do you have do you
have any kind of plans for you do what
you look forward to
I try I mean this time I was gonna start
applying for jobs but the scam wasn't it
wasn't a great one so I thought
and put that out for a little bit it's
been a lot of putting things off things
are still working out
and I plan to get a job hopefully
and not just
live with my parents forever as nice as
that is
um
yeah I want to be independent again
what are the things that keep you going
what are the things that you help you
uh well my family do a lot and also when
we first got the diagnosis
we started a bucket list
um just one of those cheesy things that
they always do
um on TV and movies
so I started putting down things that I
wanted to do
and somehow a lot of them came true so
they took away my I had to surrender my
driver's license which I just got and
was loving I did that
um
quite reluctantly
um so I decided what I wanted to do most
was Drive everything I could possibly
get my hands on I've driven a bus
hgvs
um
monster truck
train
um a London Underground
tank
um yeah that was particularly
interesting
um digger
helicopter
um
motorbike
a crane
a boat
and a yacht
um
trying to think of the whole list this
is this is one of the memories not great
um
I've also seen some wonderful people
there I've met Michelle Obama and
um
other
influential people in my life I went
fishing with them Paul Whitehouse and
Bob Mortimer
because I was really interested in in
the TV show
and we had a good day down south fishing
by a river it ended up only being me
that actually caught a fish that day
quite a big one as well but yeah they're
both really friendly nice people I've
been to South Africa went on a safari
um
I've been to New York just had some good
times despite having a brain tumor
um and that's what I'm going to carry on
doing living life to the fullest because
when it when it feels like it's getting
taken away from me you realize how much
you've not actually lived
sure everyone's got a life but
are they actually out there living it or
are they just waiting for tomorrow
I actually have something something for
you
I'll show you this
if you if you take that if you press
it's a video if you press play
hi Laura it's Mary we want to wish you
all the best with your health and hope
you can battle this terrible illness for
as long as possible we'd like to give
you this lionesses sign shirt a Euro's
winner shirt nonetheless wow and we just
wanted to wish you all the very best
you've got our support we're right
behind you and take care
oh that's so cool
thank you so much that's so awesome
yeah
um I was a big fan of football that is
very impressive did you watch all the
games yeah we we managed to get tickets
to the final
and that was amazing
um
I think the work that they've done has
changed a generation but I enjoyed that
match it was probably one of the best
days of my life loved it
so I was gonna say that
um
the she mentioned the shirt on the video
and we actually have someone special
today
to give it to
no way
[Music]
hey
hi lovely to meet you you too oh my God
I have a shot here from all the girls
so here's they see it oh wow thank you
so much no worries it's great to meet
you
and I have two tickets for you to come
and watch our derby at the yeti ad
against United yeah in a few weeks so oh
wow be nice for you to come together so
much
amazing
hi everyone hello
probably display it wow
did you watch in the summer did you
watching yeah it's the final as well oh
really was you at the game
yeah and the at the end it was at both
finals women's was so much better
I'm glad I was at the men's and I just
thought that day I was like wow this
time next year we could actually be here
ourselves and and you won as well
exactly
so Laura how does it feel to meet the
legendary
pretty cool
I'm not sure many people have can say
that they've done that and they've got
look
that is very cool Colin thank you so
much for coming here I know you
your schedule is very busy so really
really appreciate that you made the time
um is there anything you would like to
tell Laura no I think it's just an
inspiration for all of us people like
Laura and when we're on the pitch I
think we try and go out there and
Inspire so many people and to bring this
shirt today I think it means so much to
me and also all the girls people like
you you inspire us to be better every
day but on the pitch I hope we put
smiles on your faces like we did this
summer and plenty more to come
exactly I prefer this shirt to the men's
on this world cup actually
it's the glow in the bathroom
I don't think so no no one's won that
yeah my shirt after I've worn it
sometimes I don't wash them because it's
like quite authentic but they stink so
yeah
exactly
amazing thanks amazing thank you
thank you so much it was lovely it's
nice to meet you all good to meet you
thank you
thank you so much it has made mine too
Laura lovely to meet you thank you thank
you very much and I hope all goes well
and I really hope to see you at the
Derby fingers crossed yeah of course
thank you lovely to meet you thank you
so much
that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
death doesn't really bother me in fact
I'm honored I've lived three and a half
years longer than I should
so
I'm very lucky you know I've I mean I
over time bonus time and why would you
be upset when you have a bonus